bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur tv fil 78 nous
vous rendez vous nouvelle édition du 7 8
il sera notamment question
d'environnement avec christine françoise
jeanneret bonsoir à vous vous êtes la
présidente divine environnement
association fondée en 1983 vous avez
donc trente ans mais l'anniversaire 30
ans de lutte vous nous le dire et tout à
l'heure le combat qui se poursuit et je
vous demanderais d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure votre point de vue sur le grand
paris express
ce super métro le gouvernement doit
rendre ses arbitrages la semaine
prochaine pour étudier la viabilité de
ce projet notamment sur le plan
financier nous parlerons des
conséquences environnementales si vous
le voulez bien
tout à l'heure pour le moment quelques
titres les sujets qui seront à
développer au cours de cette édition de
ce 5 février opération débrayage pour
les salariés du technocentre renault à
guyancourt environ 150 personnes se sont
rassemblées pendant une heure devant le
site
la sphère dominici revu et corrigé par
des étudiants de droit de l'université
de versailles saint quentin
ils ont reconstitué le procès qui en
1957 avait condamné à mort à gaston
dominici la surprise à l'issue des
plaidoiries l'accusation version 2013 a
été réfutée
connaissez-vous le l'ifi cette technique
de communication sans fil basés sur la
lumière une façon de ne plus utiliser
les ondes électromagnétiques des
chercheurs de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines ont créé une
start up pour développer leurs procédés
et puis en culture les 10 ans de
l'estaminet à magny les hameaux avec une
combine un concert très inattendu du
parrain ii à la salle le musicien
bernard lubat une soirée totalement
décalé vous verrez quelques extraits
tout à l'heure le fait du jour de ce 5
février c'est donc cette mobilisation
toujours forte à des salariés de renault
image réaction à suivre
une nouvelle série de débrayages
aujourd'hui chez renault les salariés de
flins dans les yvelines mobilisez vous
allez le voir des appels à la grève ont
aussi été lancées afin de dénoncer les
accords de compétitivité proposé par la
direction et qui prévoit vous le savez
8000 suppressions de postes à travers la
france une colère d'autant plus
importante que le gouvernement a donné
son feu vert à ce remaniement cette
réorganisation le ministre arnaud
montebourg invite les syndicats à signer
l'accord salariés de renault et salariés
des sociétés de prestations entrons en
résistance
le message a fédéré ce matin entre 150
et 180 salariés du technocentre renault
de guyancourt
l'enjeu protesté encore contre la
direction qu'ils tiendraient selon les
syndicats un discours volontairement
catastrophiste pour effectuer des reculs
sociaux sur les 7500 suppressions de
postes annoncées 2000 concerne avec 4
une catégorie de personnel qui n'a pas
forcément la militante
disons qu'ils sont à la fois mobilisés
et démobilisés mobiliser parce que bien
sûr ils sont inquiet par tous qui ont
lors on va leur proposer
et puis démobilisé parce que ils sont
dégoûtés d'être traités de cette façon
là avec un coup ils sont les meilleurs
et puis un coup ils sont mauvais ils
sont trop nombreux et ils sont trop
payés quoi parmi les manifestants ce
matin noël d'orient ingénieur chez
renault depuis 1987
il estime que le diagnostic de la
direction est erronée depuis le début
l'indicateur à surveiller selon lui en
priorité c'est la productivité qui
résume ainsi produire plus en
travaillant moins il vient de remettre
aux différents syndicats un dossier
d'une cinquantaine de pages ou une
détaille ses propres contre propositions
en misant sur le développement des
véhicules d'entrée de gamme
moi ce que je propose aux documents
c'est qu'on devienne de microsoft est de
retour de glee c'est à dire là
celui qui est le moins cher et qu'il
fabrique un produit standard on se pose
plus de questions quand on veut une
voiture et qu'on n'y connais rien en
voiture ou en achète à sandero mais par
contre on la produit en france parce
qu'on a des usines et plus productive
donc on sait la produire pas cher en
france
effectivement ça fait baisser la main
d'oeuvre directe mais au moins on garde
des usines en france et on n'aura autour
tout ce qui est service tout ce qui est
conception des véhicules qui restent en
france
en attendant d'obtenir des réponses noël
d'orient restent mobilisés pour sauver
la marque
les syndicats eux aimeraient étendre
leurs mouvements à l'ensemble de la
filière automobile
la direction de renault a quant à elle
annoncé le versement d'une prime à
l'intéressement fin février
cela ne changera rien pour nous prévient
christophe delaine et nous avons aussi
demandé à alain schmitz le président ump
du conseil général des yvelines ce qu'il
pensait de l'avenir de l'automobile
notamment forcément dans le département
le département qui aident toutes ces
entreprises
je suis inquiet sur l'industrie
automobile française dans les yvelines
pas forcément plus qu'ailleurs au
contraire je pense que les yvelines ont
beaucoup d'atouts en revanche ce qui
s'est produit le nez peut se produire
partout ailleurs je crois que nous
sommes
à la merci et
d'un effondrement actuel du marché
européen donc du marché français d'où la
nécessité de produire hors de france et
hors d'europe pour les deux grands
groupes français et que ça repose en
termes stratégiques
la remise en cause de leur implantation
sur tout un ensemble de sites à
l'intérieur de l'hexagone
alors oui peut-être pourquoi pas ce qui
s'est produit à aulnay peut se produire
partout ailleurs nous ne sommes
certainement pas à l'abri d'une telle
décision j'allais dire d'abord de la
part des décideurs
l'atout que nous avons c'est qu'en
termes de recherche et de développement
et psa et renault sont implanter
durablement dans les yvelines avec
l'effort que nous on pour installer vd
comme sur le plateau de satory
j'ai tout espoir tout laisse à penser
que ces deux groupes privilégieront les
sites yves les lois nous serons présents
salon de genève le mois de mars prochain
puisque dans le cadre de la r&d nous
avons aidé au véhicule innovant véhicule
du futur véhicule électrique véhicule
comment j'allais dire intelligent voilà
en étant poursuit cette cette action à
travers justement la création de petites
entreprises innovantes
toujours dans le secteur de l'automobile
de renault à peugeot à présent avec
cette autre information des salariés du
site de rennes vont rejoindre le site de
poissy le département été contacté par
la direction de peugeot pour trouver des
solutions de logement à ses 200 salariés
et c'est urgent a déclaré alain schmitz
ils se sont tous mis autour de la table